[Music]
foreign
there's nothing I love more than comedy
stand up sitcoms skate shows women's
football
hilarious but TV comedy stopped being
funny a long time ago the comedy
industry is now run by people who
understand humor in the same way the HIV
virus understands empathy as in they
don't they can't and they're destroying
the entire thing the most important
quality for any comedian is that their
inoffensive
marginalized Community but if you
disagree with the prevailing narrative
then it doesn't matter how marginalized
you are you'll be treated like a gender
fluid lesbian in Saudi Arabia Dave
Chappelle was universally considered one
of the greatest comedians that's ever
lived then he made some jokes about the
alphabet people and all hell broke loose
what if I was Chinese but but born in
this [__] body that's not funny
and for the rest of my life I had to go
around making that face hey everybody
I'm tiny
and everyone get mad stop making that
face that's offensive what
this is how I feel inside
because it's fine to make jokes about
black people white people gay people
Jews Asians Latinos and feminists but
don't you dare suggest women don't have
massive schlongs the only reason they've
survived is because he's so successful
he's uncancelable it's the same with
Ricky Gervais Ricky is hated by woke
comedians because he's hilarious
understands primary school biology and
can pay his gas bill neither Ricky nor
Dave would be able to do their material
if they were starting comedy now we now
have comedians celebrating their
colleagues being canceled for saying
things they disagree with graham
lindehan's show was prevented from going
ahead the Edinburgh Fringe Comedy
Festival and loads of comics responded
with celebration and approval because
the comedy industry is all about
diversity and inclusion and if you
aren't on board you will be excluded
faster than you can recite your pronouns
why because they're desperate to be on
BBC comedy shows that are watched by six
pensioners who haven't worked out how to
go online successful British shows like
the master report mock the week have
been canceled whilst others like live at
the Apollo and the last leg are
hemorrhaging viewers because no one
watches comedy to find out what a middle
class 22 year old thinks about politics
in the US it's no better as huge shows
like Jimmy Kimmel Stephen Colbert
Saturday Night Live under Tonight Show
have all embraced political posturing
over comedy this has given rise to some
Dynamite sketches such as this one
[Music]
you're watching Newsmax kids at one it's
white Power Rangers but first it's Ted
Cruz Street
[Music]
let's ask our resident medical expert
Joe Rogan
and some horse medicine well why would a
bird take horse medicine I'm a human and
I took horse medicine
c-r-n-t critical race Theory and I think
it stands for Caucasian rats trampled
speaking of suspicious what do you call
a trans woman that walks into an
abortion clinic
her name is Rebecca and she's a
fantastic person
there are teens and opinions are all the
same Trump is a fascist everyone who
voted for him is a racist and the
Democrat and Brilliant I can't remember
a single routine by any of those Comics
mocking Joe Biden if you can't take the
piss out of Joe Biden a man who's more
Dead behind the eyes and Tutankhamun
then you really are in trouble and
obviously you can't make fun of Kamala
Harris as it's never acceptable to laugh
at someone with learning difficulties
space is exciting
it Spurs our imaginations
and it forces us to ask big questions
space
it affects us all
and it connects us all
when we look up at the night sky and see
the stars comedians hate Trump because
he's funnier than most of them and sells
way more tickets like him or not you
have to admit Trump's Netflix special
would keep you on the edge of your seat
even Joe Biden will be able to stay
awake through the entire thing I'd
prefer a hunter Biden comedy special who
wouldn't want to listen to a dynamite
routine about taking cocaine in the
White House toilet getting arrested and
having the contents of your laptop
disgrace your entire family to be fair
to Hunter I don't know any man who could
survive having his laptops internet
search history being thoroughly examined
that's one exam we would all fail
everyone knows that comedy used to be
funnier 15 years ago there are jokes you
used to be able to make that would
simply not be allowed today like this
next up Thomas Beatty announced he was
going to have a baby but what was
unusual about the whole Affair okay what
have you got don't we have that he was a
man that is a pregnant male transsexual
that's what was it was him having the
baby okay Sean James we wrote it was an
abomination
[Applause]
our team will accept that answer as
being the same as ours that's fine yeah
each was an Abomination well that's nice
when the baby was born yeah and he or
she said to the doctor is it a boy or a
girl do you think the dogs just went how
dare you
this is a channel 4 comedy show Channel
4 is the most liberal and Progressive
out of all the UK TV channels they would
rather host a show called we agree with
everything JK Rowling says than
broadcast material like this now what
what what what
the only comedian in this clip who
didn't soil himself at this footage
being leaked is Sean Lock and that's
because he's dead just like TV comedy
comedy is now so Toothless and weak it
makes your dementia ridden 92 year old
grandmother look like a roided a pit
bull we used to watch these shows and
comedians because they spoke truth to
power and mocked the elite nowadays the
only reason to watch TV comedy is to
find out what the elites want you to
think the most honest comedy show in the
UK is on the Dave channel it's called
comedians giving lectures because that's
what TV comedy is now so get your
notepads out because another fresh-faced
ethnically ambiguous diversity box
ticker is about to tell you what you're
supposed to think so now what do you do
mate absolutely
foreign
[Music]